classement soir en soie pour qu'ils
racontent et vous ces histoires vous
savez très précisément à qui vous
adresser ses films à visée au public
deux entre 12 et 14 ans j'essaie de
garder cela comme cibles en tête mais en
fait que ça valait 4 5 ans jusqu'à 70 80
ans donc et public s'est agrandie
énormément beaucoup plus large que je ne
pensais mais parce que on a dit beaucoup
lorsque le star wars a commencé que il y
avait un message dans chacun des
épisodes on a pensé un message avec
guerre du vietnam notamment
est ce que pour la menace fantôme par
exemple il ya un message aussi le
message de la menace fantôme est plutôt
le fait qu'il faut vivre ensemble savoir
vivre ensemble notre avantages mutuels
que toutes les formes de la vie ont le
droit d'exister
tous les êtres humains tous les animaux
toutes les créatures mais à vous voir
georges ducassou êtes nous avait l'air
très paisible très normal or il ya plein
de personnages absolument pas normal
dans ce que vous avez imaginé alors d'où
ça vient dans le tête de l'univers de
tolkien fait penser au seigneur des
anneaux d'un peu de western d'un peu de
bande dessinée doudou c'est venu tout ça
dans ma vie m'a influencé différencie
des motifs qui existait depuis mais il
est d'année mélangez tout seul dans un
format plutôt cinéma du synthé matin
huit anciens c'est c'est un peu rare et
peut-être que ça va être difficile vous
avec la menace fantôme vous revenez en
arrière c'est à dire vous recommencez
par le par le début vous auriez
peut-être pu être plus ordonnée si j'ose
dire ce que j'ai fini pas faire c'est en
feutre
ils sont six épisodes 12 heures j'ai
commencé leur milieu et avancer
maintenant gérer vers les racines vers
le début mais maintenant je sais
d'imaginer le produit fini les douze
équipes ont affalé ch-146 intéressante
est ce qu'il y à une théologie de la
guerre des étoiles avec au mexique
lorsque le film est sorti
l'église a dénoncé cette nouvelle
théologie walis croyances qui sont
toutes les religions partagée par toutes
les infirmières et donc applicable
je pense que la plupart des idées dans
un premier film également des publics
voyez ça plus comme quelque chose de
bouddhistes et maintenant on va un peu
plus vers des chrétiens mais finalement
c'est très oecuménique soit simplement
rappelé qu'outre le fait vous ai fait
des courts métrages que vous êtres avec
coppola que vous avez fait american
graffiti donc tout là toute la saga
vous avez même fait un clip avec michael
jackson et donc on vous traite
quelquefois de visionnaire ou de léonard
de vinci du 20e siècle
est ce que ça vous fait plaisir et est
ce que ça vous agace lorsqu'on dit que
vous êtes simplement marchands de jouets
[Musique]
je suis un cinéaste indépendant
donc j'ai le droit dérivé avant leur
doctrine n'est pas les ressources qu'un
studio hollywoodien henry je suis basé à
san francisco 4 au studio et san
francisco
il ya falsification anglais s'est basé
sur des disques et des films de coppola
défi et moi je sais des jouets c'est une
entreprise assez exceptionnel parce que
ça a duré quatre ans il faut faire des
milliers de costumes ou faire des
tournages et puis il faut dire que à 90%
c'est ça c'est de l'image numérique et
de ce fait une trentaine est tourné en
numérique partie sur pellicule prochain
film soit totalement c'est beaucoup plus
facile
la question des saisies redevient alors
vous faites un cinéma tout à fait
exceptionnelle mais qu'elle est vous le
cinéma que vous aimez j'aime bien les
documentaires jusqu'à la fiction j'ai
commencé d'ailleurs comme un signe un
documentaire
je préfère en faction et documentaires
alors là vous êtes vus vous êtes avec
yoga c'est le sait le personnage que
vous préférez j'aurais yak cinélivres
mais là il fait des quatre numéros avec
à chaque fois pour chaque épisode c'est
le personnage préféré de la menace
fantôme sa nouvelle monte au nez très
pâle performance est donc certain de mes
passagers france juste parce que je
voudrais montrer pdc a beaucoup d'albums
qui sort beaucoup de produits dérivés
vous faites jamais de cauchemar avec vos
personnages jouer mes enfants et je
pense que ça va être plus imaginatif
cette chose positive
merci jean roucas détenus dans ce
journal
[Musique]